hook up my generator to my truck trucks
don't like to start in these kind of
temperatures so you got to have a way of
warming them up and what mine has isn't
a electrical outlet that heats the block
heater the oil pan and the battery in it
to warm it up so it can turn over so
I've had this hooked up for two hours
now gonna start it up and today I got a
drive across the bridge to get across
the river at this whoever's not broken
up you can start working on something
off my trail since I stuff it won't even
start here this is typical kind of
problems you're always running into you
here once it gets below zero equipment
doesn't like to run very good start and
has problems this to go inside and get a
torch and hopefully I can heat this
metal up and get this ice to fall out in
there so I can turn this thing over I
don't plan on letting a little 20 below
zero stopping me I never do
boom
they need to warm up for a while now
it's time to get the dogs all watered up
now that I know the dog trucks gonna be
running and load them up load my sled up
load up some extra gloves chainsaw
chainsaw files chainsaw tools good boy
then gets hitting the front seat your
boss alright we're ready to rock and
roll here
you